wir haben gestern für die heutige
aussprache insgesamt eine redezeit von
acht stunden beschlossen
wir beginnen mit dem geschäftsbereich
der bundeskanzlerin und des
bundeskanzleramtes dass das wort der
prozess der fraktion dr alexander
gauland
[Musik]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
der bundesminister des inneren hat die
migration die mutter aller probleme
genannt
es gehört seit monaten zum
außenpolitischen mantra der
bundesregierung diese mutter aller
probleme das in afrika und asien
fluchtursachen bekämpft werden sollen
in diesem zusammenhang ist es höchst
verwunderlich dass unionspolitiker
erklären die bundeswehr denke über einen
einsatz in syrien nach das würde
zweierlei bedeuten mit deutscher
beteiligung wurden in syrien neue
fluchtursachen geschaffen und die
bundeswehr könnte in kampfhandlungen den
russischen streitkräften verwickelt
werden
krieg auseinandersetzung mit russland
frau merkel
ich hoffe nicht dass sie das wirklich
riskieren wollen aber welche strategie
volk die bundesregierung wirklich in
afghanistan nur die bundeswehr ebenfalls
angeblich die sicherheit deutschlands
verteidigt haben die taliban weite teile
des landes wieder unter ihre kontrolle
gebracht
seit 17 jahren stehen deutsche truppen
dort und je länger sie im einsatz sind
desto mehr afghanen kommen als
asylbewerber nach deutschland bekämpfen
wir damit tatsächlich fluchtursachen ich
fürchte nein meine damen und herren
zitat wir erteilen einer ausweitung der
zuwanderung aus drittstaaten eine klare
absage denn sie würde die
integrationsfähigkeit unserer
gesellschaft überforderung verstärkte
zuwanderung würde dem inneren frieden
gefährden und radikalen kräften vorschub
leisten
zitat ende
so steht es geschrieben im wahlprogramm
der cdu csu von 2002 aber sie haben
nicht geklatscht
das war eine korrekte prognose die frage
ist nur wer die kollegen der union warum
haben sie das nicht verzicht der innere
friede in unserem land ist in der tat
gefährdet eine bis geht durch unsere
gesellschaft ich glaube da gibt es
keinen dissens ich fürchte allerdings
dass es erheblichen lizenz in der frage
gibt von wem diese gefährdung ausgeht
sehen wir näher hin sonntag in köthen
zwei afghanen schlagen hat den deutschen
zusammen der mann stürmt samstag in
dortmund drei männer der
täterbeschreibung zufolge vermutlich
nordafrikaner stechen einen deutschen
lieder samstag in mainz zwei araber
greifen einen somalia mit messern an und
raubten ihn aus
samstag in wiesbaden mehrere männliche
personen die als dunkelhäutig
beschrieben werden belästigen junge
frauen samstag in fulda ein schläger der
beschreibung zufolge südländer verfolgen
einen 52 jährigen nach einem discobesuch
und schlagen ihn bewusstlos donnerstag
in friedberg 16 jähriger syrer sticht am
bahnhof auf einen 18 jährigen landsmann
an meine damen und herren ich spreche
hier ab finden sie nicht auch
liebe kollegen von den linken dass es
wieder zeit wird für ein konzert gegen
rechts die ideologisch verbohrt wie
verfangen im politischen taktieren muss
man sein wenn die erste reaktion auf die
ermordung eines landsmanns die sorge ist
der tod könne den politischen gegner
nutzen
ich wiederhole meine frage
wer gefährdet den inneren frieden in
diesem land auf der ley tusk eine
vorschau auf der linksextremen webseite
in die media ist unter dem titel zutat
bewaffnet euch zu lesen
zitat ein aufgesetztes schuss aus einer
gaspistole auf einen nazi am kopf oder
am herz ist sofort tödlich da braucht es
keine umstände um legal oder nicht an
eine scharfe pistole ranzukommen zitat
ende
wer gefährdet den öffentlichen frieden
wenn man unsere politischen mitbewerber
und schon ihren einwänden zuhört dann
brot allerdings gefahr von rechts
schauen wir nach chemnitz am rande eines
volksfestes hatten sogenannte
flüchtlinge drei chemnitzer mit messern
attackiert einer der drei verblutete an
ort und stelle die beiden anderen
mussten schwer verletzt ins krankenhaus
gebracht werden
das volksfest wurde abgebrochen wie beim
folgenden totschlag in köthen besetzt
einer der täter keine
aufenthaltsberechtigung hunderte
chemnitzer machten spontan von ihrem
demokratischen grundrecht auf
versammlungsfreiheit gebrauch taten ihre
empörung über die folgende
einwanderungspolitik der kanzlerin und
von merkel
sie nannten das zusammenwirken das war
übrigens ein straftatbestand im
strafgesetzbuch der ddr die ddr presse
bezeichnete proteste die zum
zusammenbruch des sed regimes führten
als zusammenrottung wenn bürger von
ihrem grundrecht gebrauch machen und die
regierungschefin
das im duktus eines totalitären staates
brandmarkt sollten
die alarmglocken bei uns allen in diesem
hause
die ehemalige grüne
bundestagsabgeordnete antje hermenau
eine leipzigerinnen beschreibt die
situation so stand nach der wende
predigten sie uns strengsten manchester
kapitalismus nur arbeiten und sparen
dann kam die finanzkrise und plötzlich
hatte es haufenweise geld für die
griechen die sich in den euro hinein
betrogen hatten und heute die
flüchtlinge
sie bekommen geld ohne zu arbeiten das
empfinden die leute als ungerecht zu
recht zitat ende von frau hermenau ihre
frühere sächsische vorsitz und liebe
kollegen wenn dann viele dieser
flüchtlinge auch noch straftaten begehen
dann ist eben schluss mit android bei
der spontanen demonstration wurde das
motto der friedlichen revolution von
1989 skandiert wir sind das volk
unter den demonstranten befanden sich
auch ein paar aggressive hohlköpfe die
ausländer raus wefer und den hitlergruß
zeigen ja das hat gar keiner bestritten
das ist unappetitlich und strafbar aber
könnte sich um eine minderheit die weder
repräsentativ für die gesamte
demonstration war noch das anliegen der
mehrheit der demonstranten die legitime
die ausländer raus schreier und
hitlergruß zeiger sind doch die größte
hoffnung für sie meine damen und herren
vom politisch medialen establishment
wenn es diese idioten und dumpfbacken
nicht gäbe wenn nur die normalen bürger
demonstrieren würden wäre das doch eine
katastrophe für sie machen immer darum
solche figuren auf und produzieren die
gewünschten bilder während sie meine
damen und herren zur linken ursache und
wirkung von drehen sich viele bürger
nicht mehr sicher und so widerlich
hitler grüße sind ich erlaube mir ins
gedächtnis zu rufen
das wirklich schlimme ereignis in
chemnitz war die bluttat zwei
asylbewerber
die birne zu beruhigen und ihnen
zuzuhören was ausgerechnet die
bundesregierung ins feuer
sowohl die kanzlerin als auch ihr
speicher verbreiteten die fake news in
chemnitz sei es zur hetzjagd auf
ausländer kommen und die medien zogen
mit der nachrichtenkanal n tv
nur ein beispiel zu nennen meldete
bürgerkriegs geilen neonazis hätten ein
trümmerfeld aus angst und blut
hinterlassen und holländischen werden
gehetzt und gejagt die wilde tiere n-tv
ohne jeden beleg hamburg ist ein gutes
rad region distanz zwischen
vereinskollegen scheiße ich will
geschlossen wird hatte ich wiederhole
meine frage wer gefährdet den inneren
frieden sie an genügend gelegenheiten
die wahrheit ist es hat in chemnitz
keine menschen jagten gegeben
der sächsische generalstaatsanwalt der
ministerpräsident hat es bestätigt die
polizeiberichte haben es bestätigt die
lokalpresse der chefredakteur der freien
presse chemnitz
ja und am ende hat ja selbst herr
seibert im namen seiner chefin die
unterstellung halb zurück tatsächlich
war die polizei bilanz wie chemnitz
nicht anders als bei einem mittleren
bundesliga
die angriffe von linksextremisten auf
polizisten im hambacher forst mit
steinen und molotow cocktails am
gleichen sonntag waren sehr viel härter
ein beamter musste ins krankenhaus
wieder vor merkel noch als albert iten
das auch nur für erwähnt werden
stattdessen werden demonstrieren bürger
unterschiedslos kriminalisiert der
nordrhein-westfälische ministerpräsident
armin laschet will aufhören mit diesen
verständnisvollen reden das seien alles
besorgte bürger er hat gewissermaßen der
bürgerlichen mitte die kündigung
ausgesprochen
sogar der verfassungsschutz präsident
wird angegriffen weil er erklärt hat es
lägen keine belastbaren informationen
darüber vor dass es in chemnitz jahr
gegeben hat was seither über herrn maßen
ausgebügelt wird lässt sich nur
interpretieren als die oberste aufgabe
des verfassungsschutzes ist die
teilnahme am kampf gegen rechts das
hätten sie ja es ist aus die
perspektive folgerichtig dass unsere
politischen mitbewerber den
verfassungsschutz dazu nötigen wollen
die auch die zu überwachen
und wissen sie was wir haben kein
problem damit
wir haben nichts zu verbergen je mehr
sich der verfassungsschutz mit uns
beschäftigt desto klarer wird sein dass
nicht die afg die verfassung gefährdet
liebe kollegen sie versuchen die
opposition zu kriminalisieren
indem sie eine auf volksfront gegen die
afg aufbauen darf ich ihn in erinnerung
rufen dass noch nie in der geschichte
eine volks von politik erfolg gehabt hat
sie tun so als hätten wir nur die wahl
zwischen multikulturalismus und
faschismus dass man auch leben kann wie
die schweiz oder die dänen oder die
schwedin kommt ihnen anscheinend nicht
in den sinn
frau merkel sie haben als sie die
hetzjagd unterstellung zurück nehmen
mussten gesagt es habe es gegeben
das ist erstens keine straftat und
zweitens in der regel gründe warum hat
es um in ihrer merkwürdigen diktion zu
bleiben hass gegeben weil die chemnitzer
schlechte menschen sind weil sie sich
als oder weil sie sich als opfer einer
falschen politik begreifen lassen diese
leute aus bösartigkeiten grundlos man
wird auf irgendeine form von
selbstkritik liebe frau merkel wohl
vergeblich warten
aber halten wir es mit mondes kühlen
nicht der mensch ist zu klein
das amt ist zu groß
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben diesem
lande und seinen bürgern nichts mehr
anzubieten also sturheit recht aber
allen beschimpfungen verbarrikadieren
sie sich im bundeskanzleramt nur weiter
von der wirklichkeit
ich wiederhole meine frage wer gefährdet
den inneren frieden in diesem land die
mir nicht
[Applaus]
das war der fraktionsvorsitzende
alexander gauland der afd der die
flüchtlingspolitik der kanzlerin erneut
heftig kritisiert
in chemnitz habe es keine hitze akten
gegeben aber immerhin so gauland hitler
grüße die dort auch zu sehen sein
gewesen sind seien widerlich